we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p here's a
funny voicemail and we're gonna do
something special for this caller we're
gonna do something special when we come
up with a title for the youtube clip for
this voicemail take a listen
oh hey david pakman Robbie in Los
Angeles to be three I can't stand videos
that have titles like shreds destroys
obliterate and I know you title some of
your videos that way facetiously and
that your audience for the most part
knows that but I wonder if it doesn't
add to the stupidity online for people
who might not know your show for
instance sometimes I've shown my friends
your videos some of them have the
facetious titling and yes I never roll
their eyes and I have to explain that
you're kidding right um so I'm just
wondering if you're gonna keep doing
that it's not a big deal but I do think
it kind of adds to the silliness of the
online commentary yeah so listen we are
going to keep doing it we do it
facetiously it I think it came out of
the right where the right started
titling videos like you know Ben Shapiro
destroys feminists with facts and logic
or whatever and here's what you have to
understand I get what you're saying that
from a completely serious point of view
if we're trying to do serious commentary
and we have you know a video called
Trump esteem plods impotently trying to
defend Trump or whatever there's some
fraction of the audience who might say
oh just on the basis of that title I'm
not taking this seriously
for the most part it's just a
calculation the net benefit of doing
that and of course the fact that after
you watch a minute
you're even 30 seconds you'll see oh
okay this is actually it's just this is
a critique of what what went on I think
it's okay and just for you just for the
caller we are going to title that your
voicemail when we upload this to YouTube
we're going to call this disgusted
caller obliterates our YouTube channel
and you know what it'll probably do
better than if we simply called it
respectful caller has mild critique of
David Pakman video titles or something
like that but in any case it's the game
you know we play the game as it needs
to be played on different platforms our
podcast episodes are titled much more
soberly because that's what's expected
there and that's what seems to do well
with the podcast audience on YouTube we
play around sarcastically using you know
some of the sort of memes that
right-wingers like to use for titles
it's working fine
I don't predict we're going to change it
anytime soon but notice that with
interviews like when we interview a
professor or something like that we
don't use the hyperbolic titles we just
call it you know whatever it is and then
put the professor's name so I think that
we are measured enough with our titling
strategy but I appreciate the concern
and the support we've got a great bonus
show for you today George Zimmerman will
just not get out of the lives of the
family members of Trayvon Martin now
suing the family for a hundred million
dollars hospitals speaking of loss it's
all lawsuits today on the bonus show
hospitals are suing Donald Trump over
his price disclosure rule that he passed
and then congressman Devin Nunez is
suing CNN over defamation alleged four
four hundred and thirty five million
dollars many lawsuits to discuss on the
bonus show today and more get instant
access I'm not talking about twenty
minutes down the lot line you get
instant access by signing up at join
pakman.com or by becoming a patron at
the $5 level at patreon.com slash david
pakman show i'll speak to you then or
otherwise tomorrow on the friday show